herzlich willkommen bei ZDF heute live
schön dass ihr wieder mit dabei seid wir
sprechen heute in dieser Folge über
unseren Rechtsstaat und darüber wie
sicher der eigentlich ist weil extreme
Parteien aktuell erstarken wird in der
Ampelkoalition überlegt wie das
Bundesverfassungsgericht besser vor
demokratiefeinden geschützt werden kann
und eine Disk diskutierte Option dabei
ist es das Grundgesetz zu ändern und
auch in der Union in der Opposition
signalisiert man Unterstützung für
dieses Vorhaben und die bräuchte es auch
denn eine Änderung des Grundgesetzes die
kann nur mit einer zwei Drittel Mehrheit
im Bundestag beschlossen werden wir
gucken heute bei ZF heute live darauf
wie gefährdet unser Rechtsstaat ist und
wie unsere Gerichte ausreichend vor dem
Einfluss von Extremisten geschützt
werden können und wir gucken uns auch
verschiedene Szenarien an eine ganze
Menge die wir heute Vorhaben darüber
sprechen wir mit dem Juristen Ulf
burmeer er ist Vorstand bei der
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte und wir
sprechen mit der Juristin Marie Müller
elmaau vom thüringenprjekt vom
verfassungsblog und wie immer hier bei
heute live sprechen wir auch mit euch da
draußen habt ihr Fragen zum Thema oder
Anmerkungen dann schreibt sie wie immer
gerne einfach hier in die Youtube Chats
oder per Mail an die jetzt
eingeblendete Adresse
und jetzt schalten wir direkt zu Ulf
Burmeier Jurist und Vorstand bei der
Gesellschaft für Freiheitsrechte guten
Abend Herr Burmeier ja hallo fr Reichelt
lassen sie uns vielleicht ganz am Anfang
dieser Sendung einmal klären so ein
bisschen die Metaebene warum ist denn
das Bundesverfassungsgericht das in
diesen Tagen so viel besprochen wird
eigentlich so wichtig für unsere
Demokratie ja das
Bundesverfassungsgericht ist eigentlich
die zentrale Instanz die unser
Grundgesetz schützt das bedeutet das
Bundesverfassungsgericht achtet darauf
dass insbesondere der Gesetzgeber also
die Parlamente in Deutschland auch
an die Grenzen der Verfassung sich
halten und es ist auch das einzige
Gericht das darauf achten kann also
andere Gerichte z.B können ein Gesetz
nicht so ohne weiteres verwerfen wenn
Sie denken dass es mit dem Grundgesetz
nicht vereinbar ist sie müssen das dann
dem Bundesverfassungsgericht vorlegen
und deswegen ist das so die ganz
zentrale Hürde auch für alle
möglicherweise extremistischen Akteure
im politischen System die versuchen
könnten die Grenzen unserer Verfassung
auszutesten soweit also zur Funktion des
Bundesverfassungsgericht wo die Regeln
für dieses Gericht stehen und welche
Änderung daran aktuell diskutiert werden
das hat sich mein Kollege Bern need
einmal
angeschaut im Grundgesetz stehen sie
geschrieben die wesentlichen
Bestimmungen zu Aufgaben und Besetzung
des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts wichtige
andere Aspekte regelt allerdings ein
eigenes Bundesgesetz und deshalb reicht
für eine Änderung dieses sogenannten
Bundesverfassungsgericht Gesetzes eine
einfache Mehrheit im Bundestag um z.B
das Wahlsystem der
Bundesverfassungsrichter zu ändern oder
die Zusammensetzung des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts es könnte
erweitert werden mit Richtern einer
bestimmten politischgesellschaftlichen
Ausrichtung und wäre als echte
Kontrollinstanz damit womöglich
lahmgelegt deshalb jetzt der Vorschlag
eine Änderung des
bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetzes
erfordert künftig eine zweirittel
Mehrheit im
Bundestag ja soweit einmal zu diesem
Mechanismus Herr Burmeier warum braucht
es jetzt laut der Ampel und laut Stimmen
aus der Union diese zwei Drittel
Mehrheit was soll denn damit ganz
konkret geschützt werden also das
Bundesverfassungsgericht soll davor
geschützt werden dass extremistische
Parteien z.B die Spielregeln für die
Arbeit des Gerichts so ändern dass es
seiner Arbeit nicht mehr nachkommen kann
dass es beispielsweise in Verfahren
ertrinkt und sich den wirklich wichtigen
Verfahren dann nicht mehr wimen kann
oder ein weiteres Risiko wäre
dass es klang im Beitrag gerade schon an
z.B ein weiterer Senat eingerichtet wird
also ein weiteres Entscheidungsgremium
in Karlsruhe das dann mit Richterin und
Richtern einer ganz bestimmten Linie
besetzt werden könnte all das wäen
Tricks um das Gericht quasi politisch
auf Linie zu bringen um es
gleichzuschalten und die Frage ist wie
kann man das verhindern und das Gericht
soll jetzt eben geschützt werden davor
dass der Bundestag mit einer einfachen
Mehrheit solche Änderungen beschließen
könnte um das Gericht lahm zu legen oder
auf Linie zu bringen und ähm deswegen
ist die Überlegung wie man es
hinbekommen kann ähm dass für solche
Änderungen in Zukunft eine zwei Drittel
Mehrheit im Bundestag und im Bundesrat
erforderlich wäre und da gibt's im
Prinzip zwei Optionen zum einen könnte
man die wesentlichen Regeln für das
Bundesverfassungsgericht direkt in unser
Grundgesetz schreiben also in unsere
Verfassung oder man könnte eine ganz
neue Methode anwenden die es bislang in
der deutschen Geschichte so nach nicht
gab man könnte sich nämlich überlegen ob
das Gesetz dass die Arbeit des Gerichts
regelt als solches nur noch mit zwei
Drittel Mehrheit geändert werden kann
das wäre ein ganz neuer ganz innovativer
Vorschlag der auf der anderen Seite aber
sicherlich auch einige Verwirrung
stiften würde äh deswegen ist meine
Sympathie eher ähm auf der Seite die
vorschlägt das Grundgesetz direkt zu
ändern und dort die wesentlichen Fragen
in der Verfassung zu regeln es gibt ja
dieser Tage aber auch Stimmen die sagen
ähm muss dieser Rechtsstaat eigentlich
noch weiter geschützt werden das ist ja
auch eine Diskussion die führen wir
gerade im Zuge der korrektivrecherche
also der Recherche zu diesem
Geheimtreffen im Potzdam wo
rechtsextreme und AFD Politiker
remigrationspläne beschlossen haben wo
es auch um das Bundesverfassungsgericht
ging daraufhin sind ja ganz ganz viele
Deutsche Menschen auf die Straßen
gegangen es gibt aktuell große Demos für
die Demokratie und erste Umfragen nach
diesen Demos zeigen auch die
Umfragewerte für die AFD sind zumindest
mal nicht weiter gestiegen ja das stimmt
natürlich
gibt es keine Alternative dazu
Parteien wie die AFD auch politisch zu
stellen wie das so schön heißt also
Ihnen mit politischen Argumenten
entgegenzutreten auf der anderen Seite
ähm zeigt das Beispiel von Polen z..b
oder von Ungarn ähm dass das nicht immer
gelingt und das Problem bei
populistischen Parteien ist äh dass sie
sich wenn sie einmal gewählt worden sind
eben sehr schnell an die Macht klammern
dass sie sehr schnell versuchen
Demokratien ähm quasi auf Linie zu
bringen Demokratien gleichzuschalten und
dafür zu sorgen dass sie nie wieder
abgewählt werden können man kann das äh
zugespitzt formulieren als das Problem
ist äh DemokratInnen und Demokraten
müssen jede Wahl gewinnen und
Antidemokraten müssen nur eine Wahl
gewinnen schon machen Sie sich den Staat
zur Beute und deswegen gibt es diese
sagen wir mal präventiven Überlegungen
wie man unsere unser Rechtssystem jetzt
widerstandsfähiger machen könnte
wetterfester sodass es einen Ausrutscher
wie eine Mehrheit für z.B die AFD
übersteht ohne das gleich unsere
Demokratie insgesamt abgeschafft
wird jetzt hört man natürlich auch in
diesen Tagen immer wieder Stimmen aus
der AFD die sagen gut diese Diskussion
die da geführt wird gegen uns wir sind
immerhin demokratisch geäht in Teilen
die ist genauso antidemokratisch also es
gibt ja schon so eine Erzählung die AFD
der AFD die sich als undererdog
repräsentiert als
anti-establishment spielen dann solche
Diskussionen nicht noch weiter auf diese
Erzählung ein nein das denke ich nicht
denn die Regeln die zurzeit diskutiert
werden sind ja nicht gegen eine
bestimmte Partei gerichtet sondern sie
sind dagegen gerichtet unsere
demokratischen Institutionen zu
Schwächen auf zu bringen oder gar ganz
abzuschaffen das heißt also diese
Regelungen sind als solche politisch
neutral sie würden ja nur dazu führen
dass man eben für wesentliche Änderung
an der Arbeitsweise z.B des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts eine sehr
breite gesellschaftliche Mehrheit
bräuchte eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit und
ich denke dass das eine gute Idee ist
und dass es sich eben auch gerade nicht
gegen eine spezifische Partei richtet
weil es wie soll ich sagen nicht
politisch aufgeladen ist das ist kein
linkes Projekt sondern das ist einfach
nur ein Projekt zum Schutz der
Demokratie auch wenn diese Diskussion
jetzt natürlich geführt werden aus
Anlass der Bedrohung durch die AFD das
ist klar ja und diese Diskussion gucken
uns mal genauer an hier gibt einmal zwei
politische aktuelle Stimmen zu dem Thema
es geht darum dass demokratiefeinde
natürlich in erster Linie politisch
bekämpft werden aber es geht auch darum
wie wir unsere staatlichen Institutionen
besser schützen können da denke ich zu
allererst an unser höchstes Gericht das
Bundesverfassungsgericht was gilt es aus
meiner Sicht besser abzusichern es gibt
bis jetzt keinen konkreten Vorschlag der
ampelvertreter es gibt Fragmente von
Vorschlägen das ist nicht durchdacht
aber klar ist wenn man es ernst meint
mit dem Thema dann muss man es genau
beleuchten und muss sich z.B auch die
Frage stellen eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit
bedeutet eine ein Drittel
Sperrminorität ja ein sperriger Begriff
eine ein Drittel Sperrminorität Herr
burmeierer was bedeutet das ja dabei
geht's um die Frage welche Konsequenzen
eigentlich drohen würden wenn
eine antidemokratische Partei
tatsächlich mehr als ein Drittel der
Mandate im Deutschen Bundestag erringen
sollte äh denn die Hälfte der
Richterinnen und Richter des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts wird ja direkt
vom Bundestag gewählt und wenn dann
jetzt eine solche antidemokratische
Partei mehr als ein Drittel der Stimmen
hätte dann könnte ohne ihre Zustimmung
keine zwei Drittel Mehrheit im Bundestag
mehr zustande kommen das heißt die
könnte dann entweder die Wahl von neuen
Richterinnen und Richtern blockieren
oder man müsste sich mit ihr einigen und
das könnte dazu führen dass dann
extremistische Personen nach karlsruh
gewählt würden äh beides eine Situation
die man sich ganz sicher nicht wünschen
kann wenn man dem
Bundesverfassungsgericht weiterhin so
viel Gesundheit wünscht so viel
effektive Arbeit wünscht wie bisher und
deswegen ist die Frage wie könnte man
aus einer solchen Sackgasse wieder
herauskommen da gibt es schon sehr gute
Vorschläge denke ich das eine könnte
sein dass wenn der Bundestag über einen
bestimmten Zeitraum sein Wahlrecht nicht
ausschöpft dass dann der Bundesrat
einspringen könnte also das andere
oberste Gremium auf Bundesebene könnte
dann anstelle des Bundestag
Richterin und Richter wählen das setzt
aber natürlich voraus dass dort nicht
ebenfalls eine Sperrminorität irgendwann
zustande kommt oder was man sich auch
vorstellen könnte ist dass das
Bundesverfassungsgericht in einer
solchen Verfassungskrise die Möglichkeit
bekäme eine Vorschlagsliste nach Berlin
zu schicken das Gericht also z.B sagt
diese fünf Personen können wir uns
vorstellen dann kann eben mit einfacher
Mehrheit aus dieser Liste gewählt werden
das könnte man sich vorstellen aber da
gibt sich ja auch noch andere Ideen
insofern ist an dem Bedenken der der
Abgeordneten der C sicherlich was dran
aber es ist äh das sind aber keine
unlösbaren
Probleme ja und zur Ernennung von
Richtern an diesem
Bundesverfassungsgericht haben wir eine
Frage aus der Community Jürgen wörheide
fragt auf Youtube wäre es nicht sinnvoll
dass Richter des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts unabhängig von
der Politik gewählt werden das wäre doch
eigentlich der beste Schutz
ähm sie sind tatsächlich nicht ganz ähm
unabhängig von der Politik weil es
natürlich eine politische Einigung geben
muss aber ähm wir haben in der deutschen
Geschichte eigentlich sehr gute
Erfahrung damit gemacht weil die
Richterinnen und Richter in aller Regel
eben nicht parteipolitisch entscheiden
ganz im Gegenteil emanzipieren sie sich
eigentlich von den Parteien die sie
ursprünglich mal vorgeschlagen haben und
der zweite wichtige Punkt ist äh die
Richterinnen und Richter brauchen
natürlich eine demokratische
Legitimation also sie müssen irgendwo
ihre ja sehr große Macht auch vom Volk
ableiten und das funktioniert ähm
bislang ebenenso dass man sie vom
Parlament wählen lässt ich denke eine
direkte Volkswahl von Richterinnen und
Richtern wäre ausgesprochen gefährlich
das gibt es in bestimmten
Konstellationen in den Vereinigten
Staaten und das ist ganz sicher kein
Vorbild wenn man sich anschaut was da
dann z.B für Werbekampagnen laufen
gerade auch wo dann mit Schmutzkampagnen
versucht wird bestimmte Personen zu
verhindern ich glaube das ist für den
demokratischen Diskurs nicht gut ähm da
glaube ich oder sehe ich jedenfalls
erstmal keinen
Reformbedarf ja lassen Sie uns noch mal
zu dieser politischen Debatte
zurückgehen die ja aktuell geführt wird
wir finden die wirklich sehr vehement
jetzt äh die Opposition äh mischt sich
auch ein sagt sie würde das auch
mittragen die Frage die ich mir jetzt
Stelle und sich auch einige User stellen
wie ist denn da der zeitliche Horizont
wie lange braucht es um so etwas zu
entscheiden das heißt wie viel Spielraum
ist da noch zeitlich also das kann
grundsätzlich sehr schnell gehen es
braucht eine zwei Drittel Mehrheit im
Bundestag also insofern müsste
tatsächlich die Unionsfraktion zustimmen
und es braucht auch ein zweirittel
Mehrheit im Bundesrat auch da müsste die
Union mit an Bord sein es braucht also
auf jeden Fall eine Einigung zwischen
der Ampel und der Union um eine solche
Mehrheit auf die Beine zu stellen und
ich denke aus Gründen der demokratischen
Kultur wäre es auch gut
die weitere demokratische Fraktion im
Deutschen Bundestag nämlich oder die
Gruppe jedenfalls der der Linkspartei
noch mit an den Tisch zu holen
möglicherweise auch die eher
versprengten Mitglieder des neuen
Bündnisses SAR wagenkncht um einfach zu
dokumentieren
dass man das auf eine breite
demokratische Grundlage stellt solche
Verhandlungen können denke ich in
wenigen Wochen abgeschlossen werden und
das gesetzgebungsäh Verfahren würde dann
auch ein paar Wochen in Anspruch nehmen
aber das wäre auf jeden Fall wenn man
sich jetzt wirklich beeilt noch bis zur
Sommerpause zu schaffen denke
ich ja und wir haben hier noch einen
User der auf ein bestimmtes Ereignis
abzielt es fragt jemand auf Youtube kann
man dies als ein Warnschuss
interpretieren dass in Bayern
mittlerweile AFD Mitglieder im
Verfassungsgericht sitzen Herr B was ist
da genau passiert und ist das ein
Warnschuss ja das ist was dort passiert
ist istind etwas besondere Konstellation
weil da eine ganze Reihe von Menschen
nach gewählt worden ist ähm zu
Mitgliedern des bayerischen
Verfassungsgerichtshofs und die
Besonderheit in Bayern ist dass eben
nicht einzelne Personen dort gewählt
werden sondern es gibt eine ganze
Vorschlagsliste die gewählt wird äh und
dort jedenfalls hat äh die CSU in Bayern
entschieden dass sie eben auch vier
Personen mit AFD Hintergrund wählen
möchte ähm wie auch immer das zustande
gekommen ist die SPD und die Grünen z.B
im barayischen Landtag haben das
kritisiert ähm da gibt es in Bayern
jetzt eine Reformdiskussion ob man nicht
dazu übergehen sollte eben statt so zu
einer ganzen Liste lieber einzelne
Personen zu wählen damit solche Effekte
in Zukunft hoffentlich nicht mehr
eintreten ja und wir haben auch noch
einen Ton eines ehemaligen
Verfassungsrichters nämlich von Peter
Huber der zu dieser aktuellen
politischen Debatte
auch durchaus kritisch steht das was
diskutiert wird ist dass man das zwei
Drittel
mehrheitserfordernis das heute im
Bundesverfassungsgerichtsgesetz steht in
das Grundgesetz reinschreibt aber es
gibt eben auch Gründe die das für
vielleicht für nicht so tunlich
erscheinen lassen vor allem dann wenn
extremistische Kräfte zusammen mehr als
ein Drittel der Abgeordneten stellen
weil dann könnten sie die Wahl der
Verfassungsrichter Blockieren der Staat
lebt davon dass wir uns für den Staat
einsetzen die Bürger müssen schon diese
Verfassung tragen und mit Leben
füllen ja die Bürger müssen diese
Verfassung tragen und mit Leben füllen
heißt das es braucht zudem noch mehr
zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement also
zivilgesellschaftliches Engagement ist
natürlich immer gut wir sehen ja auch
gerade dass Menschen auf die Straße
gehen für über ihre Überzeugung zum
Schutz der Demokratie und ich finde das
ist ein starkes Statement dass die
Demokratie den Menschen in Deutschland
eben nicht egal ist insbesondere auch
den Menschen in den sogenannten Neuen
Bundesländern nicht in den östlichen
Bundesländern denn auch dort gibt es ja
große Demonstrationen und ich ich
persönlich michich beweg t es auch weil
ich in Leipzig studiert habe auch wenn
ich aus den neuen Ländern stamme ist es
einfach für mich ein sehr schönes Bild
zu sehen dass die Menschen eben sagen
wir haben uns die Demokratie erkämpft
1999 und wir wollen Sie uns jetzt auch
nicht von extremistischen Kräften wieder
wegnehmen lassen ähm die Bedenken die
Herr Huber anspricht Stichwort
sperminorität sind natürlich valide aber
ich denke da gibt es eben auch
Möglichkeiten wie man eine solche
Blockade einer Wahl von
verfassungsrichterinnen und richichtern
im Bundestag aufheben könnte wir haben
eben schon so ein paar Optionen
diskutiert der Bundesrat könnte
einspringen oder oder das
Bundesverfassungsgericht könnte
Vorschlagslisten nach Berlin schicken
das wären so zwei
Ideen das sind jetzt alles Ideen und
Vorkehrungen um die Rechtsstaatlichkeit
quasi sehr sehr festzuschreiben deswegen
die Frage kann man denn sowas überhaupt
zu 100% sichern nein das ist denke ich
eine Sorge die Herrn Huber umtreibt die
ich teile wenn es tatsächlich in
Deutschland eine Mehrheit gäbe für um
jetzt mal ganz zugespitzt zu formulieren
für ein Führerprinzip ja wie wir das
eben seit 1933 hatten in Deutschland
wenn es wirklich eine breite
gesellschaftliche Mehrheit gäbe ähm dann
wäre sicherlich eine Verfassungsordnung
auf Dauer nicht widerstandsfähig genug
aber ähm selbst in den autokratischen
Staaten die wir jetzt in Europa gerade
erleben wie in Ungarn z.B oder in Polen
wo es jetzt gerade Gott sei Dank sich
reparieren lässt da haben wir eigentlich
gesehen dass diese autokratischen
Parteien nie eine Mehrheit hatten
zunächst mal sondern sie haben zunächst
mal nur relativ knapp gewonnen und haben
dann eben ihre neugewonnenen
Möglichkeiten eingesetzt um die
Demokratie zu schwächen und um zu verhin
h dass sie jemals wieder abgewählt
werden können und ich glaube um dieses
Szenarien geht es ist übrigens gilt
übrigens auch für die NSDAP die in eben
gerade keine keine alleinige Mehrheit
hatte keine absolute Mehrheit hatte die
auch nur mit einer Koalitionsregierung
zunächst an die Macht kommen konnte und
dann eben innerhalb von wenigen Wochen
die Weimar Republik ausgehült hat und
das ein Parteiensystem etabliert hat und
es geht um diese Situationen wo
autoritäre Parteien im Volk gar keine so
breite Mehrheit haben sondern allenfalls
eine relative Mehrheit aber wo sie dann
eben alles versuchen um nie mehr
abgewählt werden zu können das ist
glaube ich das Szenario vor dem wir
unsere Demokratie noch besser schützen
können als
bisher ja wir haben jetzt
eine ganze Weile über das
Bundesverfassungsgericht und seine
Besonderheit gesprochen und eben auch
über diese zweiittel Mehrheit die jetzt
gefordert wird jetzt ist ja aber das
Bundesverfassungsgericht nicht das
einzige Organ einer funktionierenden
Demokratie und man fragt sich auch wie
kann das an anderen Stellen in Zukunft
passieren
wenn es bestimmte Wahlergebnisse gibt
wie entwickelt sich da die ja die
Personallage wäre denn in ihrer in ihrem
Bild auch so eine so eine
Zustimmungsquote bei der Besetzung von
anderen Spitzenbeamten poosten denkbar
also da kann man sich natürlich
viele Gedanken machen denn natürlich
kann eine
Regierungsspitze sehr viele Positionen
in der Verwaltung in der Exekutive neu
besetzen auf der anderen Seite muss man
sehen
gibt es natürlich auch gute Gründe dafür
dass eine einfache oder eine absolute
Mehrheit im Deutschen Bundestag
grundsätzlich reicht um den
Bundeskanzler die Bundeskanzlerin zu
wählen und dann eben die Exekutive zu
leiten ich glaube da muss man wirklich
im Einzelfall genau schauen welche Ämter
möglicherweise so eine herausgehobene
Bedeutung haben dass wir da eine
breitere Legitimation wollen z.B eine
zwei Drittel Mehrheit ä Richterinnen und
Richter des Bundesverfassungsgerichts
sind aus meiner Sicht ein sehr gutes
Beispiel dafür aber ich glaube generell
zu sagen wir brauchen für alles eine
zwei Drittel Mehrheit ähm das wäre für
den demokratischen Diskurs auch nicht
gut denn Demokratie lebt ja auch von dem
Wettbewerb zwischen politischen
Alternativen und wenn immer zwei Drittel
im Bundestag sich einig sein müssen auch
für quasi normale politische
Entscheidung dann gäbe es eigentlich
keine große Möglichkeit mehr für die
Menschen in Deutschland tatsächlich mit
Wahlen einen Politikwechsel
herbeizuführen schon heute leidet die
Politik im Bund sehr ä an dener starken
Blockade Macht des Bundesrats schon
heute braucht es für viele wesentliche
Entscheidungen sehr breite Mehrheiten
und ich glaube viele Menschen nehmen das
schon als Stillstand als politikblockade
war und deswegen würde ich eher davor
warnen noch weitere Blockaden auf
Bundesebene z.B in die Gesetzgebung
einzubauen oder auch in die Besetzung
von Positionen in der
Verwaltung so viel also zu dieser
aktuellen politischen Debatte Herr B
vielen Dank dass Sie meine Fragen und
die Fragen unser Community beantwortet
haben und schönen Abend noch nach Berlin
ja sehr gerne vielen
Dank ja und von dieser aktuellen
politischen Debatte in Berlin gucken wir
jetzt mal nach nach Thüringen in diesem
ostdeutschen Bundesland wird im Herbst
2024 gewählt und die Umfragewerte für
die AFD sind hoch es gibt's ein Team aus
rechtswissenschaftlerinnen des
sogenannten verfassungsblocks und das
untersucht derzeit welche rechtlichen
Spielräume eine autoritärpopulistische
Partei ausnutzen könnte wenn sie
Mehrheiten gewinnen würde vor welchen
Herausforderung stünde unsere Demokratie
also dort neben diesen aktuell
diskutierten Veränderungen beim
Verfassungsgericht noch es gibt noch
viele andere gesellschaftliche Bereiche
die davon betroffen werden und zu diesem
thüringenprjekt spreche ich jetzt mit
Marie Müller Elmer vom verfassungsblog
guten Abend hallo guten
Abend ja Frau Müller Emmer vielleicht
erklären Sie uns als erstes mal wie
dieses Thüring Projekt genau
funktioniert was gucken Sie sich und
Ihre Kollegin da ganz genau
an ja genau wir sind ein Team von Z
Leuten und wir untersuchen anhand von
Szenarien welche juristischen Spielräume
eine autoritärppulistische Partei in
einem deutschen Bundesland hat wenn sie
staatliche Machtmittel an die Hand
bekommt dabei gehen wir eben von
unterschiedlichen stbedingungen aus es
kann also z.B bedeuten dass eine
autoritärpopulistische Partei über eine
Sperrminorität verfügt wie das eben Herr
wohmeer schon erklärt hat oder eben auch
dass sie tatsächlich regiert und eben
einzelne Ministerien
stellt davon ausgehend entwickeln wir
sozusagen Erzählung
für die wir uns vor allem an
Geschehnissen und Ausland im Ausland
orientieren also an Ländern wie Ungarn m
oder Polen und überprüfen eben inwiefern
sich diese Vorgehensweisen diese formal
legalistischen Vorgehensweisen ähm auch
in Deutschland juristisch und politisch
durchsetzen lassen würden okay jetzt
begeben wir uns quasi mal in dieses
Szenario wir gehen davon aus dass eine
Partei wie sie die beschreiben dort äh
eine ja die Möglichkeit einer
sperminorität erreichen würde oder sogar
vielleicht regieren würde welche
Bereiche gucken Sie sich da ganz konkret
an und zu welchen können Sie uns auch
schon erst Erkenntnisse
mitteilen wir gucken uns eigentlich alle
gesellschaftlichen und politisch
relevanten
Felder an also das Wahlrecht das
parlamentsrecht natürlich die Justiz
die Zivilgesellschaft den Kulturbetrieb
den Wissenschaftsbetrieb
ähm den Medienbereich äh die Verwaltung
ähm und durchleuchten eben in all diesen
einzelnen Aspekten die rechts und
Verfassungsordnung Thüringens nach
Gefährdungslagen und Schwachstellen und
eben auch einfach nach
missbrauchsanfälligen
Ansatzpunkten einer dieser
missbrauchsanfälligen Ansatzpunkten
Ansatzpunkte besteht
in dem Amt der Landtagspräsidentin die
Landtagspräsidentin ist eine Person die
im allgemeinen politischen Diskurs
bisher ziemlich stark unterbelichtet ist
also noch gar nicht so präsent ist
obwohl sie eigentlich ein ganz
entscheidendes Amt inner hat sie
repräsentiert eben das Parlament und ist
dafür verantwortlich die
Funktionsfähigkeit des Parlaments zu
gewährleisten wenn jetzt dieses Amt in
den Händen einer autoritärpopulistischen
Partei ist die an dieser
Funktionsfähigkeit überhaupt kein
Interesse hat dann könnte das eben ganz
besondere Gefahren für die Demokratie
mit sich
bringen welche Gefahren sind das ganz
konkret wir können ja mal in dieses
Szenario gehen was was würde dann ganz
genau
ablaufen also die Landtagspräsidentin
verfügt über ganz entscheidende
Kompetenzen ähm zum einen ist sie in der
Lage den Direktor ähm des Landtags ähm
ohne Angabe von Gründen vorzeitig in den
Ruhestand zu versetzen und ähm kann eben
versuchen diesen Posten mit einer
ihrgenehmeren
Person zu besetzen ähm dieser Person
untersteht dann die Verwaltung
das betrifft eben zum einen die IT das
heißt es könnte sehr gut sein dass sich
dann grüne und linke Politiker innen
plötzlich darum Sorgen machen müssen
wer da jetzt konkret Ihre E-Mails liest
und es betrifft aber auch den
Wissenschaftlichen Dienst der gerade für
die Opposition eine ganz wesentliche
Institution ist weil der
Wissenschaftliche Dienst dafür
verantwortlich ist die Opposition mit
information zu versorgen und wenn sich
die Opposition nicht mehr darauf
verlassen kann dass diese Information
vollständig oder eben auch überhaupt
korrekt sind dann ist die Opposition in
ihrer Arbeit stark
behindert okay wir haben also dieses Amt
der Landtagspräsidentin was sie haben es
gerade gesagt erstmal jetzt medial
vielleicht nicht so im Spotlight steht
was aber eine ganz entscheidende Rolle
in so einem Szenario einnehmen könnte
machen sie sich auch Gedanken darüber
wie man diese Schwachstellen der
Demokratie oder besonderen Stellen der
Demokratie verändern könnte bzw Sie
anpassen
könnte ja im Idealfall ist es uns eben
möglich nicht nur Schwachstellen und
gefähdungslagen zu identifizieren
sondern auch
Lösungen zu entwickeln es ist aber eben
zum einen so dass sich nicht alle
Probleme rechtig lösen lassen ähm also
z.B wenn es um das Amt der
Landtagspräsidentin geht ist es eben so
dass die stärkste Fraktion
nach politischer Tradition das
Vorschlagsrecht für dieses Amt
hat das heißt
eine autoritärpopulistische Partei wird
eine Kandidatin vorschlagen was noch
nicht konkret bedeutet dass sie auch
gewählt wird
das können Abgeordnete selber für sich
in geheimer Wahl
entscheiden
aber es besteht eben bestimmtes
Interesse daran diese Wahl erfolgreich
durchzuführen weil sich der Landtag nur
dann konstituiert wenn die
Landtagspräsidentin gewählt ist
was ich damit verdeutlichen will ist
dass es in dem Fall nicht unbedingt eine
rechtliche Lösung gibt die sich finden
lässt um diese Wahl zu verhindern oder
auf eine bestimmte Art und Weise zu
steuern sondern das ist da eben ganz
entscheidend auf die demokratischen
Parteien ankommt und darauf ankommt dass
diese Parteien sich auf Kandidatinnen
einigen und diese eben auch geschlossen
wählen zum anderen lässt sich natürlich
in bestimmten Fällen über rechtliche
Lösung nachdenken das kann eben
Verfassungsänderung betreffen aber auch
den Erlass von einfachen Gesetzen da ist
es aber eben so dass diese sich
politisch oft schwer durchsetzen lassen
weil eben gerade Verfassungsänderung
über eine zweirittel Mehrheit erfordern
und es wahnsinnig schwer ist einen
solchen Konsens politisch zu
mobilisieren und nicht zu allerletzt
glauben wir als jingprjekt eben nicht
daran dass ich eine wasserdichte
Verfassung ähm bauen lässt weil ähm
jeder rechtliche Vorschlag
ähm der als Lösung daherkommt ähm eben
auch ein Missbrauchsrisiko ausgesetzt
sein kann und ähm das Problem des
verfassungsmissbrauchs damit nicht löst
sondern eben allenfalls verlagert ja ist
ja auch ein Thema das wir eben schon mit
Herr Burmeier angeschnitten hatten lass
sie uns mal auf einen anderen Bereich
gucken äh der aktuell auch viel
besprochen wird nämlich was in ihrem
Szenario mit der Medienlandschaft in
Thüringen passieren
würde ja also
m wir haben kürzlich recherchiert und
veröffentlicht dass ein
Ministerpräsident in Thüringen in
kompletten Alleingang eben alle Rundfunk
und medienstaatsverträge
kündigen
könnte diese Medien und
rundfunkstaatsverträge konstituieren
eben Anstalten wie ARD ZDF oder auch den
MDR
in Thüringen es ist nun ebeno dass
dieser Ministerpräsident ähm sich um
diesen ähm um diese Verträge zu kündigen
ähm weder mit der Regierung ähm also mit
den restlichen Regierungsmitgliedern
abstimmen muss noch auf die Zustimmung
des Landtags angewiesen ist das heißt er
kann vollkommen für sich alleine diese
Unterschrift setzen und diese Verträge
kündigen ähm das würde dann den
öffentlichrechtlichen Rundfunk erstmal
vor relativ große Herausforderung
stellen weil seine Finanzierung erstmal
auf unsicheren Beinen wäre weil Personal
entlassen werden müsste grämien neu
besetzt werden müssten
und ähm auch das
Bundesverwaltungsgericht in den 80ern
geurteilt hat dass
und ZDF dann eben auch keine
sendeberechtigung mehr in diesen
in diesem Bundesland hätten
es ist unklar inwiefern das eben auch
für für digitale Angebote gilt
aber äh es würde auf jeden Fall erstmal
eben Unsicherheit entstehen und äh und
undich rechtliche Rundfunk vor
Herausforderung
gestellt mhm sie befassen sich mit in
diesem Szenario
neben dem Medienbereich neben dem
parlamentarischen Bereich auch noch mit
sogenannten konsultativen Volksbefragung
ein kompliziertes Wort vielleicht können
Sie uns einmal erklären was das ist
welchen Zweck die überhaupt verfolgen
und was sie dazu biser rausgefunden
haben ja konsultative vololksbefragung
kommen auf den ersten Blick als
Instrumente der direkten Demokratie
daher sind es aber eigentlich gar nicht
konsultative Volksbefragung sind
letztendlich Fragen die die Regierung an
die Bevölkerung stellt sie sind
rechtlich unverbindlich das heißt das
Ergebnis muss sozusagen nicht
zwingendrechtig umgesetzt
werden und sie beinhalten in der Regel
eben suggestiv Fragen also sie geben
eine bestimmte Antwort eigentlich schon
vor
und autoritäre Populisten nutzen dieses
Instrument wahnsinnig gerne weil es in
ihn ihn eben dabei hilft ihre
Entscheidung zu legitimieren autoritäre
Populisten setzen sich ja mit dem Volke
gleich und
beanspruchen für sich den Willen des
Volkes sozusagen direkt zu
repräsentieren das heißt mit Hilfe
dieser konsultativen Volksbefragung
können sie ihre eigenen Entscheidungen
ähm höher legitimieren weil sie sich
immer darauf berufen kann dass ja die
Bevölkerung gerade diese Entscheidung
ähm gerade diese Entscheidung will ähm
und ähm in Thüringen ist es eben so dass
die Verfassung
ähm sowohl volksbescheide als auch
Volksbegehren als Instrumente der
direkten Demokratie vorsieht und ähm
diese konsultativen Volksbefragung nicht
explizit ausschließt ähm der Bayerische
Verfassungsgerichtshof hat vor ein paar
Jahren ähm schon mal für Bayern
entschieden dass diese konsultativen
Volksbefragung dort mit der Verfassung
ähm unvereinbar sind ähm aber es wäre
eben für Thüringen auch ganz besonders
sicher wenn man ähm diese konsultativen
Volksbefragung
ähm auf verfassungsrechtlicher Ebene ähm
ausdrücklich ausschließen
würde sie haben gerade gesagt das sind
äh
befragungsmechanismen die autoritä äh
autoritärpopulist
Parteien Kräfte kennen und schätzen
haben sie da Beispiele für uns wo man
das aktuell schon beobachten kann
äh ja also Orban hat z.B von diesem
Instrument ziemlich vehement Gebrauch
gemacht
und hat dann so Fragen gestellt wie sind
sie nicht auch dafür dass wir anstatt
von Migration
ungarische Familien schützen sollten das
macht auch noch mal deutlich was ich mit
sogestiv frage meine also diese
Volksbefragung Zielen eben schon ähm in
eine ganz bestimmte Richtung und ähm
denenen dann eben wie gesagt der
Legitimation ähm einer bestimmten
Entscheidung und ähm auch die AFD hat
auf Bundesebene äh beantragt eben in der
Verfassung
ähm eine solche Möglichkeit der
konsultativen äh Volksbefragung
einzuführen ähm es ist also kein
Geheimnis dass ähm auch die AFD an
diesem Instrument äh Interesse
hat ich fass mal zusammen wir haben ein
durchaus interessantes Amt der
Landtagspräsidentin
wir haben konsultative Volksbefragung
als ein Instrument was wir als solches
hier in Deutschland bisher nicht kennen
was aber im Bereich des Möglichen liegt
und eine Veränderung des Mediensystems
alles was sie jetzt aus diesem Szenario
in Thüringen schließen wie schätzen sie
denn den Nutzen von solchen Szenarien
ein wir sehen die Szenarioanalyse eben
als ganz entscheidenden Beitrag
für die whrhaftigkeit einer Demokratie
ähm diese Szenarien Stellen eben ganz
besonders heraus
mit welchen Taktiken diese autoritären
Populisten operieren weil sie eben
schrittweise vorgehen und weil sie
formal legalistisch Vorgehen
diese Szenarien können eben zum einen
aufzeigen worin diese Schritte bestehen
und damit dafür sorgen dass sie nicht
als
entlegende Rechtsänderung daherkommen
die niemanden interessieren sondern dass
das eben Schritte sind die uns alle
etwas
angehen und kann damit die
Zivilgesellschaft dazu animieren wachsam
zu sein und genau
hinzugucken und zum anderen ist es eben
möglich Schwachstellen und
Gefährdungslagen zu identifizieren und
genau auszumachen auf wen und was
es ankommt um bestimmte Konstellationen
zu
verhindern Frau Müller Emmer vom
verfassungsblog zum thüringenprojekt
vielen Dank auch an sie und Ihnen noch
einen schönen Abend vielen dank ihnen
auch ja soweit zur aktuellen politischen
Debatte rund um den besseren Schutz des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts und eine
kleine
Szenarioanalyse die uns so ein bisschen
gezeigt hat wo die Reise hingehen könnte
sagt ja Marie Müller Elma wenn
autoritäre populistische Parteien
Mehrheit generieren können ich danke
euch dass ihr dabei wart ich danke euch
wie immer für eure Fragen und Kommentare
und wünsche euch noch einen schönen
Abend